Ich bin in Frankfurt, die Bahn ist wieder aufgeregt.
Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, wie mich die Bahn heute wieder aufgeregt hat.
Allerdings nur in einer Richtung.
Heute Morgen war es halbwegs pünktlich, aber wie schaffen die das wieder?
Es ist alles pünktlich.
Ich laufe zum Südbahnhof.
Okay, vier Minuten, aber vier Minuten ist nix.
Es ist alles pünktlich.
So.
Ich gehe oben in Frankfurt-Südbahnhof an, klar ist 20 minuten.
Wie zum, wie geht das?
Wissen die nicht, wo ihre eigenen Züge sind?
Das müssen, ich meine, die müssen doch zusammenstoßen, wenn die das nicht wissen.
Oh, aber ganz ehrlich Leute, mir ist es lieber auf dem Heimweg, als auf dem Hinweg, weil...
...auf dem Heimweg ist dann irgendwie danach Ruhe und auf dem Hinweg musst du danach noch einen ganzen Tag arbeiten.
Ich schreibe keine Bahnbewerbung.
Kackfickerverein, Alter.
Mein Gott, das ist das Drecks...
...Kacknubs, Alter, das ist der Wahnsinn, das ist so ein Drecksladen, mann.
Ganz schlimm.
Ah ja, und wisst ihr was das allerbeste war?
Ich war ja heute auf der Arbeit vor Ort in Frankfurt.
Und was meint ihr?
Wie, wie viel, wie viel habe ich heute geschafft, also nein, wie viel mehr habe ich heute dadurch geschafft, dass ich vor Ort war?
Oder besser sollte man vielleicht fragen, wie viel, wie viel, wie viel weniger habe ich geschafft, dadurch, dass ich vor Ort war?
Also ich habe heute im Endeffekt eigentlich so gut wie nix machen können.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen besprochen, recht zufällig, weil ich mal wieder einen gesehen habe vor Ort, mit dem ich aber genauso gut hätte mit den Teams reden können.
Nix, nix sinnvolles irgendwo, das hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt.
Was für ein Ding.
Deutlich weniger, ja, ich hab...
Also ich wollte, ich wollte heute zwei Sachen machen, das weiß ich noch.
Ich wollte Systemd-Unit-Files anpassen für eine Kiste, weil die komplett im Arsch sind.
Die sind so kaputt, dass...
Also wir haben es geschafft Systemd-Unit-Files zu haben, die 50% Server-Auslastung generieren.
Das musst du erstmal schaffen, ich weiß, also mir war bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt gar nicht klar, dass du ein Unit-File basteln kannst,
das kannst du ja nicht mal programmieren nehmen, dass du ein Unit-File definieren kannst, was 50% Server-Auslastung verursacht.
Also wir haben es aber geschafft.
Ja und was war das andere, was ich machen wollte? Hab ich schon wieder vergessen.
Unit-Files wollte ich machen.
Hab ich nicht komplett hingekriegt.
Das andere weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr.
Ach, irgendwas, was ich im Config-Management gebaut hab, noch aufräumen, ja.
Aber wer muss aufräumen? Workarounds.
Habt ihr schon mal erlebt, dass ein Workaround gebaut wurde und, ähm, also, ich muss, okay, ich muss jetzt anders anfangen.
Also habt ihr schon mal erlebt, dass ein Workaround wieder abgeschaltet wurde, der eingeführt wurde mit der Aussage, das ist nur vorübergehend.
Also habt ihr das Abschalten solch eines Workarounds schon mal erlebt? Also mir fällt es jetzt spontan nicht ein.
Ich kenne sehr viele Workarounds bei uns, die genauso entstanden sind, so nach dem Motto, ah, das machen wir jetzt bloß temporär und dann schalten wir es wieder ab.
Aber...
Was für ein Ding?
Eine selbstgebaute Webseite, die damals als Einkaufszettel begonnen hat.
Meinst du, die, die To-Do-Anwendung, die wir mal als Beispielanwendung gebaut haben, oder...
Das passiert bei euch, nicht schlecht.
Nee, die gibt es nicht. Die gab es auch nie, fertig. Das war irgendeine Übung, als ich mir damals, glaube ich, Sveld angucken wollte oder so.
Da ist er wieder. Der ist wieder.
Da ist er wieder. Die Schriftart Preserief. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es bei uns schon mal vorgekommen ist, aber das Abbauen von Workarounds kommt relativ selten vor.
Und manchmal ist es sogar so, dass es gut ist, dass es so selten vorkommt, ja.
Wir haben letztens ein paar Server umgeschaltet, auf neue, und heute ruft mich einer an und fragt mich, sag mal, Max, gibt es die alten Systeme noch?
Da habe ich halt gemeint, na ja, also offiziell nicht, aber die stehen noch da. Warum, was will er dann wissen?
Da hat er gemeint, ja, können wir die wieder irgendwie aktivieren? Ich sag, warum sollten wir denn die alten Systeme wieder aktivieren wollen? Wir haben doch jetzt neue Systeme.
Und da hat er mir erzählt, das musst du dir mal vorstellen, da hat er mir erzählt, ja, die haben ein, das ist unglaublich bescheuert, ja, die haben ein Update gepusht,
das irgendwie fünfmal so groß war, als normale Updates, weil irgendeiner vergessen hat, irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten zu entfernen.
Also normales Update für irgendwelche Außendienst-Apps, oder was auch immer wir da so alles verteilen, normale Updates sind so keine Ahnung.
Also 10 MB ist viel, und das war 150 MB. Und da haben sie Panik geschoben, dass es die neuen Kisten nicht schaffen.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommt, dass die Server-Auslastung ein Problem ist, das Problem dürfte eher die Leitung sein.
Wenn dann auf immer, wenn man die neuen Kisten nicht schaffen kann, dann ist das ein Problem.
Aber ich habe ihnen schon vor drei Jahren gesagt, gefühlt, jetzt, wo wir so alles in der Cloud machen, wären doch Updates Server das erste, was man in die Cloud stellen könnte.
Dann hat man alle Bandbreitenprobleme gelöst. Ja, der Meinung war man auch, aber dreimal dürfte ich raten, ob die Updates in der Cloud gelöst werden.
Und dann haben sie mir gesagt, ja, das ist ein Problem. Und dann haben sie mir gesagt, ja, das ist ein Problem.
Ich kann euch sagen, nein die sind nicht in der Cloud, da steht ein Prototyp in der Cloud
seit in einem Jahr und der steht da halt gut rum.
Max Power, danke für den Sub, Sander, Massive Subscription, 15 Monate, bin ich, doch jetzt,
jetzt, war einfach nur zu langsam.
Massive Subscription hier, du bist der Gift-Leader.
Ich weiß gar nicht, dass es hiervon Symbol gibt.
Ja Leute, wir machen heute wieder nichts großartiges, ich bin einfach ongekommen, weil ich nicht
immer, weil ich nicht mal will, dass ich teilweise einfach irgendwie 8 Tage oder so nicht online
kommen, deswegen, wenn ich es abends irgendwie auf die Reihe kriege, dann mache ich den Stream
an und wenn wir nur mal eineinhalb Stunden ein bisschen schwätzen, weil, ja so nach
der Arbeit, ich kann mir da nicht irgendwelche High IQ Themen aus den Fingern saugen, die
man da jetzt so übers Knie brechen kann, das funktioniert nicht.
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst, oder gibt es irgendwas spannendes, außer dass die nette,
was hatten wir gestern, habe ich irgendwas spannendes verpasst, außer dass die Bahnen
immer noch Drecksficker sind, so, das muss jetzt einfach noch mal gesagt werden.
Sylt, ist, nein, ich klicke keine deutschen Trends an, wenn ich deutsche, wenn ich das
schon sehe, wieder hier die Trends, das Gartenstells Video, ganz wichtig, das passiert nicht von
heute auf morgen, warum sollte ich das übertreiben, warum soll, vor allem warum sollte ich da
irgendwie eine Kündigung einreichen, einfach mal so prophylaktisch, ja, das mache ich nicht,
wenn überhaupt mache ich das, wenn ich was neues habe, was hältst du von Fresh, also
das was ich von Fresh gesehen habe, weiß ich nicht so genau, wann und ob ich es verwenden
will, es ist Deno, damit hatte ich noch nie großartig was am Hut und es ist React, aber
Server-Site React irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich weiß noch nicht wann man das braucht,
naja, ich glaube das ist wie so in ziemlich allen anderen Jobs, wenn du noch nicht wahnsinnig
Erfahrung hast, was heißt denn, was heißt denn Noob-Entwickler, hast du irgendwann mal
eine Ausbildung gemacht, einsame Spitze, danke schön für den Sub, nee, Moment, Spitzensahne,
Einser-Spitzensahne, was auch immer, aber danke schön für den Prime-Sub, hast du eine
Ausbildung, also solange du eine Ausbildung gemacht hast, ist gut, da stehen die in Deutschland
unglaublich drauf, Hauptsache du hast eine Ausbildung gemacht und ansonsten, na gut,
also würdest du denn deine Skills einschätzen, überhaupt schon weit genug fortgeschritten,
dass wenn du einen Udemy-Kurs, quasi einen Udemy-Beginner-Kurs zur Hälfte fertig gemacht
hast, dass du wirklich schon bereit bist einen Programmier-Entwicklungs-Job anzunehmen,
das ist vielleicht ein bisschen optimistisch, oder?
Was sagst du zu SAP, ERP und ABAP, boah, hör mir bloß auf, Alter, ABAP, das ist ja
das Schlimmste, was ich, okay, nee, Kobold ist noch, aber, also ganz ehrlich, ABAP ist
das, was ich an Beispielen gesehen hab, ist ja wirklich, ja ganz abartig, guckt euch das
mal an, Alter, das sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie Kobold, plus fast noch schlimmer,
nein wir machen definitiv keinen ABAP-Stream, TSFox, danke für den Sub, also, ich persönlich
stehe jetzt nicht so sehr auf SAP-Sachen und ABAP ganz und gar nicht, aber, das muss nicht
heißen, dass das eine schlechte Ausbildung ist, weil du machst ja nicht unbedingt deine
Ausbildung als SAP-ERP-ABAP-Entwickler, das machst du vielleicht im Betrieb, aber du
bist ja zumindest dann Fach-Informatiker, Anwendungsentwicklung, Fach-Informatiker, Systemintegration oder
meinetwegen auch, äh, wie heißen die zwei neuen, oder drei neuen Fach-Entwickler, ich
kann mir das immer noch nicht merken, warum nicht, ich mein, die Ausbildung kann auch
trotzdem sinnvoll sein zu machen, ja, nur weil ich jetzt sag, SAP-Kekel heißt noch lange
nicht, dass das keine gute Idee ist, eine Ausbildung zu machen in dem Bereich, ja, und
man muss ja auch auf Fairness halber sagen, SAP-Consultants und SAP-Leute verdienen Fett
Kohle, und ich hab gehört, man verdient auch richtig Fett Kohle, wenn man SAP, äh, wie
nennt sich das so, Lizenzberater oder sowas ist, ne, wie nennt sich das, nicht Lizenzberater,
da gibt's so ein spezielles, da gibt's so ein spezielles Wort, für das man den Leuten
quasi erklärt, ähm, welche Lizenzen sie kaufen, kaufen müssen und so, irgendwie, was
weiß ich, irgendwas was SAP-Consultants machen, das ist das gleiche wie bei Microsoft letztendlich
auch oder bei Oracle, Oracle ist ganz schlimm, Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie bescheuert
oder wie Pepega die Lizenzpolitik von Oracle ist, also, überlegt mal, überlegt mal, also,
wir fangen mal mit nem einfachen Beispiel an, und falls jemand Ahnung hat, kann er mir
ja schreiben, ob das immer noch so ist, aber das letzte Mal, als ich mich mit Oracle Lizenzdingern
beschäftigt hab, war das noch so, also, wir fangen mal einfach an, ihr habt ein Hardware-Server
mit nem Quad-Core-CPU, 96, 90 GB RAM, und wollt da Oracle drauf laufen lassen, Oracle-Datenbank,
so, Oracle lizenziert nach CPU-Kernen, ihr habt eine Hardware-Kiste, und ich rede jetzt
nicht von Hyper-Threading oder sowas, ja, ihr habt eine Hardware-Kiste mit vier Kernen,
für wieviel Kerne müsst ihr Lizenzen bezahlen bei Oracle?
Das ist noch die einfache Frage, ihr habt vier Kerne, für wieviel Kerne müsst ihr Lizenzen
bei Oracle bezahlen?
Wie gesagt, das ist noch einfach, nee, nee, es ist einfach, es sind tatsächlich vier,
es sind tatsächlich vier, ihr habt vier CPU-Kernen, ihr müsst vier Kerne bezahlen als Lizenz,
aber jetzt kommt die trickreiche Frage, ihr macht eine Oracle-VM auf einem ESX-Cluster,
der Rauch spoilert schon wieder, ihr macht eine Oracle-VM auf einem ESX-Cluster und gebt
dieser VM vier CPU-Kerne, aber die Hardware, worauf euer ESX läuft, hat 16 CPU-Kerne, für
wieviel CPU-Kerne müsst ihr Oracle jetzt lizenzieren?
16, korrekt!
Das ist so ein total bescheuertes System, übrigens wisst ihr wo das nicht so ist, wenn
ihr die Oracle-Virtualisierung benutzt, dass irgendwas Red Hat passiert, das Oracle-Virtualization,
ich weiß nicht, die haben so eine total verkackte eigene Virtualisierungslösung, die ich wirklich
keine Sau kenne, die die benutzt, außer Leute, die Oracle-Lizenzen sparen wollen, das könnte
dieses Ding sein, keine Ahnung, ich hab das nur einmal gesehen, ja irgendwie sowas hier,
also wenn ich sowas schon sehe, nee das ist nicht VirtualBox, Oracle hat VirtualBox gekauft
und seitdem irgendwie nichts mehr an VirtualBox gemacht, ja geil, aber das will man halt vielleicht
nicht, man möchte halt wirklich bloß eine mit vier Kernen oder so, das ist wirklich,
also muss man echt sagen, Virtualisierung ist die Hölle, was Oracle angeht, ich frag mich
ernsthaft, warum, da hab ich bis heute keine wirkliche Erklärung für gefunden, warum gibt
es immer noch so viele Unternehmen, die Oracle verwenden, also ich kann euch sagen, warum
wir auf der Arbeit, jaja das muss Oracle Enterprise Linux sein, Oracle hat natürlich
einen eigenen Red Hat Fork, um nochmal extra Geld machen zu können, also bei uns auf der
Arbeit ist es so, wir haben Oracle immer noch, weil irgendwann mal unsere Hauptanwendung,
die wir so haben, mit Oracle angefangen hat und wahrscheinlich relativ viel Oracle Magic
verwenden und keiner sich traut, was anderes zu benutzen, so, wir haben mal ein bisschen
rum experimentiert mit einem Oracle zu Postgres Übersetzungslayer, aber da ist nie großartig
was rausgekommen, nein, wisst ihr auch nicht, warum ich das machen will, habt ihr eine Idee,
warum benutzen so viele größere Unternehmen Oracle wahrscheinlich aus dem gleichen Grund
wie wir oder weil es halt mal eingeführt wurde irgendwann und sich jetzt keiner traut
es abzuschaffen oder wie gesagt, ich bin nicht der große Datenbank Pro, das sage ich ja
auch immer wieder, mal angenommen, ich baue jetzt eine neue Anwendung, wann würde ich
Oracle nehmen, anstatt einer Postgres Datenbank zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal Postgres, weil
Postgres kenne ich mich zumindest halbwegs brauchbar aus, ja das stimmt aber das Support
ist mega kacke, ja wird es, bei uns sind auch schon ein paar Oracle Sachen in der Oracle
Cloud, ja das wird weniger, ich verstehe aber gar nicht, warum man jetzt bei was neu
mit Oracle anfangen würde, ob es die Support Sache ist, weiß ich nicht, weil du kriegst
kaufbaren Support mit Sicherheit auch für Postgres und auch für MySQL, wobei ich ja
persönlich Postgres Fan bin, also den verstehe ich nicht, leuchtet mir nicht so genau ein
wenn ich ehrlich bin, keine Ahnung, ich muss mal kurz paar Tabs schließen, ist bisschen
zu viel los hier, Alter jetzt erschreckt mich doch nicht so, Javascript just got way faster,
wann, da habe ich heute morgen einen Blog Eintracht drüber gelesen und zwar wann ist
eine neue Javascript Engine in ZIG programmiert, ZIG, fragt mich bitte nicht was ZIG ist,
sondern eine Programmiersprache, aber es ist anscheinend keine Programmiersprache zu abgedreht
um neue Javascript Runtimes zu implementieren, was auch immer, ich weiß nicht was der Vorteil
ist, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, Javascript im Backend ist eh nicht so meins, ja ich verstehe
dass viele aus praktischen Gründen was mit Node machen, aber ich finde Javascript an
sich keine schlechte Sprache, also Javascript hat das geschafft was C++ in den letzten
Jahren versucht hat, aber klicklich gescheitert ist, aus einer ziemlich wild zusammengehackten
unlogischen Sprache eine recht gute sinnvoll benutzbare moderne Programmiersprache zu machen,
ja Javascript hat immer noch komische Sachen, zum Beispiel dass not a number nicht gleich
not a number ist und komische Dinge, aber trotzdem, Javascript wenn man mal von diesen komischen
historischen Legacies Sachen mal ausplanen ist nicht schlecht, die haben sinnvolle Sachen
eingeführt, ja die haben Async Await eingeführt, das hat auch ein paar Jahre gedauert, wisst
ihr dass C++ auch Async Await einführen will oder einführen wollte oder einführt gerade,
nur dass die Syntax und die Standard Library Unterstützung einfach absolut grottenschlecht
ist, also ich weiß nicht wie man es so verkacken kann wie C++, aber ich muss mich jetzt nicht
wieder über C++ aufregen, ihr wisst alle dass ich C++ kacke finde und ich jedes mal Anfälle
bekomme wenn ich was mit C++ machen muss und wisst ihr dass wir demnächst was mit C++ machen
müssen wieder, weil und ich glaube das habe ich gestern schon erzählt, meine zwei Raspberry
Pi Pico V Kisten zum testen sind gestern angekommen, wenn ihr sogar Stadtprima Hafen Block schon
was drüber schreibt, ja und das ist Microcontroller Gedöns das ist C++, ich weiß ich weiß es
gibt Micropython für dieses Zeug, aber ganz ehrlich Cringe, Commander Krieger raidet
mich für 87 Leute Dankeschön, Massive Huge Raid, du hast hier glaube ich keinen guten
Tag ausgesucht mich zu raiden, ich bin halb am schlafen weil es heute anstrengend war und
hänge hier so quasi so zu 80% unter der Schreibtischplatte und penne halb ein, also wer erwartet das
hier High IQ Zeug abläuft heute nicht, Cringe wird C, aber richtig Cringe, es gibt leider
noch genug Leute die C++ programmieren müssen, weil sie nicht drumherum kommen wir tun ja
die ganzen Unreal Entwickler leid, die da ein bisschen was einbauen wollen oder dann
da habe ich ja Glück, IQ Boost, ich hoffe das liegt nicht, aber er die Tür auf den Kopf
gefallen ist, wie war die Bahnfahrt heute, ok ich sag dazu nur eins, wenn du wissen willst
wie die Bahnfahrt war dann guck dir einfach mein Twitter Post von heute an und jetzt rate
mal wie meine Bahnfahrt gewesen ist, was meinst du, war die Bahnfahrt gut, neutral oder schlecht,
was denkst du, rate mal, die war richtig, die war ganz besonders toll, überdurchschnittlich
ja, normalerweise macht man ja aktuell immer so diesen Gag, wenn irgendwas was imitiert
nur in schlecht, dann sagt man ja heutzutage immer so XYZ auf Wish bestellt, ich frag mich
gerade ob die Bahn auf Wish bestellt mich sogar besser wäre als das Original, normalerweise
ist auf Wish bestellt ja immer so Synonym mit Kacke, aber es kann eigentlich gar nicht
noch beschissener werden, das heißt wenn du die Bahn auf Wish bestellst und irgendwelche
China Chinesen dann Bahn fahren, dann klappt das wahrscheinlich besser als mit unserer,
ich mein die sind da bestimmt schmerzloser, wenn sich in China einer auf die Bahnschiene
gelegt, da wird wahrscheinlich einfach drüber gefahren, ich muss nicht umsteigen, ich hab
das große Glück, dass ich direkt durchfahren kann, von Frankfurt nach Hanau und nicht umsteigen
muss, was aber auch im Umkehrschluss heißt, ich habe die einfachstmöglichste Bahnstrecke,
die es gibt, nämlich normalerweise 25 Minuten ohne umzusteigen in eine Richtung oder in
die andere Richtung, fertig und sogar bei mir klappt das so gut wie nie, wie ist das
erst für Leute, die wirklich länger fahren müssen, die vielleicht sogar täglich fahren
müssen, die nicht das Glück haben wie ich, dass sie so oft Homeoffice machen können oder
Leute die vielleicht, mag es ja geben, wirklich pünktlich bei einem Termin sein müssen oder
pünktlich beim Flieger sein müssen, du kannst das doch komplett vergessen, du kannst doch
eigentlich nur Taxi fahren, das ist doch unmöglich das mit der Bahn zu machen, es geht doch eigentlich
gar nicht, also ja wenn du bei Aliexpress bestellst, wenn du mit EU Priority Line bestellst,
bist du schneller da aus China, du kannst, also wenn du dich bei Aliexpress mit einem
Paket verschicken würdest mit EU Priority Line, bist du schneller da als mit der Bahn,
sehr gut die Chinesen übertreiben es teilweise schon ein wenig ja, das ist unser allerlieblinges
Thema, ja also meine Bahnfahrt war halt wieder ganz besonders toll, wo bin ich jetzt eigentlich
stehen geblieben, genau also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob morgen oder am Freitag, da gucken
wir uns den neuen Raspberry Pi an, wobei es ja nicht ein neuer Raspberry Pi ist, sondern
das ist ein Raspberry Pi, der Raspberry Pi heißt, aber eigentlich gar kein Raspberry
Pi ist, aber ich bin trotzdem mal gespannt warum ich das Ding nehmen sollte im Vergleich
zu einem ESP32, wenn es ja wenigstens für 9 Euro wäre, ich bezahle ja mein ganz normales
Monatsticket, ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das irgendwie anteilmäßig erstattet bekomme,
ich habe die Jahresvariante mit so einem elektronischen Ticket, keine Ahnung, zumindest was ich weiß
ist, ich könnte das als 9 Euro Ticket benutzen, von der Größe her wie ein ESP ungefähr
so groß wie ein D1 Mini, wobei der D1 Mini tatsächlich noch ein bisschen kleiner ist,
also angerechnet muss ich sagen, weiß ich gar nicht, was ich auf jeden Fall machen könnte
ist, ich kann mein normales Ticket als 9 Euro Ticket verwenden und auch außerhalb vom Rhein-Main-Gebiet
fahren, irgendjemand hat gefragt, kommst du aus Hessen, ja komm ich arbeite in Frankfurt
und ich komme aus Hanau, weiß nicht wer, wo, das, irgendjemand hat das gefragt eben gerade,
ja als Japaner wahrscheinlich auch, wahrscheinlich jedes Land wo die Bahn nicht nur unglaublich
viel kostet, sondern auch ordentlich was liefert dafür, vergisst das, dass man das im viertreichsten
Land der Welt nicht auf die Reihe bekommt, man muss sich das auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
wir sind das viertreichste Land, also wirtschaftsmäßig, Land der Welt, aber das mit der Bahn geht
nicht, wir sind noch nicht mal sonderlich groß, im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern, da
kommst du auch her, Pog, oder nicht Pog, Hanau hat ja leider die letzten Jahre über ist eher
negativ in Erscheinung getreten, nach außen hin, aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, Hanau
ist eigentlich genauso kacke wie Frankfurt, nur nicht in dem kompletten Umfang, also sowohl
in Hanau als auch in Frankfurt haben ihre schönen Seiten, aber halt auch viele, aber
eigentlich zu 90%, das ist kacke, ich bin bei uns heute durchs Ort gelaufen und da hat
irgendjemand mit so Spraydosen an die Wand geschmiert, Berlin kann jeder, Frankfurt ist
Kunst, ich weiß nicht ob das ein Zitat ist, aber das stand so mit Spraydosen an die Wand
gemalt bei uns, und da hab ich mir auch gedacht, okay also ganz im Ernst, die Seite, die ich
von Berlin gesehen hab, war genauso abartig wie Frankfurt, also im Ernst, Berlin Hauptbahnhof
und Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, es ist kein großer Unterschied, das erste was ich in Berlin am
Hauptbahnhof hatte, ist, dass mich ein Penner angehustet hat, und da dachte ich mir so, das
ist ja wie in Frankfurt, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass du den Ausgang im Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
besser findest als in Berlin, weil der hat zwei und du weißt nicht welche Seite welche
ist, also Berlin ist, zumindest die Ecke am Hauptbahnhof ist genauso versifft und kacke
wie Frankfurt, Innenstadt, Hauptbahnhof und drumherum und genauso kacke wie Frankfurt
irgendwie wie Hanau, Hauptbahnhof und Freiheitsplatz, aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich haben sowohl
Berlin als auch Frankfurt als auch Hanau ihre schönen Seiten, wobei ich sagen muss,
die schönen Seiten von Frankfurt, die seh ich selten, ich bin nicht nördlich vom Taunus,
ich bin, ich glaube Hanau ist so südöstlich vom Taunus, ich bin aber auch bloß 20 Minuten,
25 Minuten weg, findest du, also ich weiß nicht, am Freiheitsplatz, guck dir mal die
Leute an die da rumgammeln, das ist ja wirklich, das ist eine Stufe vor Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof,
es ist vielleicht noch nicht Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, aber es ist eine Stufe vor Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Im Bahnhof selber ist das bei uns auch gar nicht so schlimm, sondern um den Bahnhof,
im Bahnhof selber ist tatsächlich ganz okay, seit da so viel Bahnsecurity rumläuft, aber
um den Bahnhof ist halt in Frankfurt totaler Abfuck, so Niederstraße, weiß nicht ob da
schon jemand mal den Genuss hatte durch zu laufen, es ist so, wann warst du zuletzt am
Freiheitsplatz, was da rumlungert den ganzen Tag, kannst du knicken, das ist eine Stufe
vor Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, naja egal, das ist absolut die Elite, nein ich war noch nie
in Paris, ich gehe auch davon aus, ja es geht bestimmt noch schlimmer, aber gerade
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, die Ecke, also wenn, aber Google Maps, also ich zeige euch jetzt
mal ganz schnell wo ihr nicht rauslaufen solltet vom Hauptbahnhof, also Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof,
hast du das Feuer am Hauptbahnhof, nee, was war, hab ich nicht mitbekommen, nee, so also
Hauptbahnhof, ja, so also der Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, das ist ein Sackbahnhof, das heißt ihr fahrt
hier rein und hier wieder raus, das ist für den Durchsatz nicht so geil, aber so ist es
halt gebaut, so und ihr könnt an verschiedenen, ich mach mal kurz das Bild an, wir zoomen
da mal ein bisschen ran, weil ansonsten erkennt man das, hier sieht man das, also ihr könnt
an verschiedenen Stellen raus, ja, die meisten Leute gehen hier vorne raus am Haupteingang,
Haupteinausgang, aber ihr könnt auch hier neben raus und ihr könnt auch hier raus auf
der Seite, hier persönlich ist mir, hier ist mir eigentlich am liebsten, aber ok, wenn
ihr aus dem Haupteingang rausgeht, hier, also, es ist eigentlich alles, überhalb der Münchner
Straße abfuck, und selbst die Münchner Straße ist schon von Arsch, von Arsch, Kaiserstraße
geht mittags, das besteht zum größten Teil aus Dönerläden, Friseurläden, Burgerläden
und sonst was, aber hier oben hin wirds immer beschissener, Taunostraße, ganz schlimm,
Niederstraße ist das allerschlimmste, links ist der Taxistand, genau, ihr fragt mich nicht
wo, links irgendwo ist der Taxistand, ja genau, hier, hier, Parkplatz, hier ist der Taxistand,
genau, also hier, Niederstraße, diese Ecke hier, Niederstraße auf Moselstraße, Taunostraße
hier, diese Ecke, Leute, wenn ihr mal, also wenn ihr denkt, die Welt ist doch gar nicht
so schlimm, dann geht ihr da einfach mal durch und ihr seid danach bekehrt, ja, also da ist
so ziemlich alles, was man nicht für möglich hält, gibt es dort, wir waren mal unterwegs
mittags auf der, auf der Kaiserstraße, hier so an dieser Ecke müsste das gewesen sein,
irgendwo Burger futtern und ich, was ich da schon für Leute gesehen hab, das harmloseste
ist Leute, die denken, sie sind Flieger, das kommt da auch regelmäßig vor, da laufen
Leute, also sie laufen nicht, die rennen, die haben, die haben sich vorher irgendwas
gespritzt oder so, die, die rennen durch die Kaiserstraße und machen so Flieger und
machen dabei, mit so ausgestreckten Armen und rennen die Straße lang, ist nicht, ist
nicht ein einziger, wirklich der Wahnsinn, nee, ist nicht nur, nee, was wollte ich sagen,
ist nicht nur ein einziger, nee, ich wollte sagen, das war nicht nur einer, den ich bisher
gesehen hab, so rum, genau, also das ist, das ist wirklich ganz, ganz abgedreht, so und hier
oben, hier oben ist halt wirklich, hier ist halt oben, hier oben ist wirklich vorbei, so
und das ist eines der, der abgedrehtesten Sachen war, die ich mal erlebt hab, wir mal,
wir waren mittags hier irgendwie Burger Zeug oder sonst was futtern, hier vorne ist irgendwie
so ein Asialaden, nee, hier ist Burger Laden, das sind die, wo ich mich mal witzigerweise
auf YouTube sponsoren lassen wollte, aber nie gemacht hab, zumindest hier waren wir unterwegs
und auf einmal kommt von hinten, also es laufen vor uns zwei Mädels, ja, schon bisschen älter
und wir hören von hinter uns, kommt einer angerennt, der rennt an uns vorbei, schlägt
der einen vor uns auf den Kopf, reißt die Handtasche mit und rennt weg und danach, da
dachte ich halt so, fuck, Alter, was ist jetzt los, gut, Frankfurt, weiß der nie und da kommt
der Hit, die schreit ihm nach, die schreit ihm nach, so nach dem Motto, Karl, was machst
du, die kannten dich auch noch, die wusste wer das ist, der sie überfallen hat, also
das ist wirklich, da ist komplette Abgründe in dieser Ecke, Alter, wer hat ein Wikipedia-Artikel,
also das ist wirklich ganz schlimm, also diese Ecke, Leute, wenn ihr jemals in Frankfurt
seid, geht aus dem Hauptbahnhof raus und je nachdem, wo ihr hin müsst, geht lieber die
untere Sache lange, ja, Gutloystraße, Münchnerstraße, Münchnerstraße ist auch so ein Ding, aber
also Kaiserstraße könnt ihr auch lang gehen, mittags da ist nix, früher waren hier die
ganzen Puffs und Zeug, aber jetzt nicht mehr, aber geht nicht oben Moselstraße, Taunostraße,
Hinterstraße, da wollt ihr nicht lang, ja am besten tatsächlich, wenn ihr die Chance
habt, wenn ihr die Chance habt, tatsächlich der Weg am Main der beste, wenn ihr auf die
Zeil wollt, würde ich ehrlich gesagt einfach mit der U-Bahn vom Hauptbahnhof weiterfahren,
ich würde gar nicht laufen, das ist nicht so weit, die Zeil ist irgendwo hier oben,
Hauptwache, hier irgendwo müsste sie sein, Rosmar, da, hier, da, ja da wollen die Leute
immer einkaufen und Zeug machen, ich weiß nicht warum, aber da ist immer viel los, fahr
am besten mit der U-Bahn weiter vom Hauptbahnhof, anstatt hier irgendwie durch Frankfurt zu
laufen, ne also die Ecke ist wirklich abartig und ich mach das meistens so, ich fahr gar
nicht mehr zum Hauptbahnhof, ich fahr immer, also fahre mit dem Zug, wo sind wir denn
hier, ich bin gerade orientierungslos, hier, Frankfurt Süd, Südbahnhof, was zum, wo ist
denn der Südbahnhof, gehst du über den Main und dann gehst du hier irgendwo hier runter,
irgendwo muss doch der Südbahnhof sein, Moment, ach da, ich bin zu weit unten, genau, ja
ich fahre eigentlich nur zum Südbahnhof mit der Bahn und ich laufe dann vom Südbahnhof
hier rauf, hier so die Ecke, es dauert so 25-30 Minuten, wenn man langsam ist, dann
hat man sich ein bisschen bewegt und da sind nicht die ganzen Assis, so kurzer Frankfurt
Guide, jetzt wisst ihr wo ihr nicht hin solltet, ey der Wahnsinn, der Fabian auch, der Frazier,
der Frazier war mal in Frankfurt, also der war das erste Mal in Frankfurt auf irgendeiner
Friseur Hair & Beauty Messe und da hab ich gesagt, weißt du was, lass mal schnell hier
McDonalds oder Burger King war mal glaube ich so genau, Burger King lass mal irgendwie
ein paar Burger futtern, waren wir da essen und sind wir da auch draußen ein bisschen
rumgelaufen, der Fabian ist auch fast vom Klaumen abgefahren, Alter, was hier rumläuft,
man, wie hältst du es hier aus, Dresden ist das komplette Gegenteil, in Dresden siehst
du eigentlich so gut wie keine Assis auf der Straße, nix, Dresden ist wirklich im Vergleich
zu Frankfurt ein, ein, ja, weiß ich wie man es hälte, Friede, Freude, gut, gut, vielleicht
solltest du dich in Dresden, wenn du schwarz bist, abends nicht alleine auf die Straße
stellen, das ist wieder ein anderes Thema, aber in Frankfurt kannst du abends auch nicht
alleine auf die Straße, in der Ecke oben, also ich würde ehrlich gesagt hier abends
nicht alleine neben der Straße lang laufen, Hamburg ist auch abartig, Hamburg kenne ich
aber nicht so viel von, Hamburg kenne ich nur den Hauptbahnhof, dann, äh, welcher Fluss
ist das in Hamburg, die Elbe ist das in Dresden, oder, über irgendein Fluss drüber, äh,
die Elbe, nee, wenn ist die Elbe nicht auch das in Dresden, Moment, Fluss, Elbe, was
ist das in Hamburg auch, ich glaube euch das jetzt, ich hab von so geografischen Sachen
keine Ahnung, ähm, und da irgendwie drüber, das war jetzt auch nicht grad schön, ja,
wo warst du, in Frankfurt, oder, oder wo, ja also es ist abartig, da will man auf jeden
Fall nicht hin, ja, ich mein Frankfurt hat durchaus auch sicherlich nette Seiten, aber
ist halt vieles, was macht eigentlich der neue Stadtteil, das soll doch irgendwie hier
unten hin, oder, es gibt doch hier irgendwie auf der Seite von meinen soll es einen neuen
Stadtteil geben, weil Frankfurt zu wenig Platz hat, hab ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
mal verfolgt, was da rausgekommen ist, und ganz wichtig, wer in Frankfurt ist, der darf
zwar nicht rein, aber Hanauer Landstraße, wo wir grad dabei sind, und machen wir mal
ein bisschen, ähm, nachdem ich mich jetzt über die ganzen Assis in Frankfurt ausgelassen
hab, machen wir mal ein bisschen IT Allgemeinbildung, in Frankfurt ist der größte Internetknotenpunkt
Europas, einer der größten der Welt, nämlich der DZX, und der DZX ist hier, da irgendwo
war Crytek in der Ecke, genau, irgendwo hier auf der Hanauer Landstraße, ich hab vergessen,
wo, ja, da in der Nähe vom Kentucky Fried Chicken ist das, hier Interaction, Interaction
sind die, die den DZX betreiben, hier irgendwo unterirdisch müsste der DZX sein.
Wenn du da reingehst, wenn du da reingehst, wirst du gewogen, und du darfst nur raus,
wenn du das gleiche wiegst beim rausgehen als beim reingehen, also wenn du da irgendwelche
schwitzigen Warzone Sessions machst, im Internetknotenpunkt, darfst du dann mal raus, oder wenn du mal
kacken musst, darfst du auch nicht raus, aber da gibt es keine Klos, du musst rauszubekacken,
warum machen die das?
Ist ganz logisch, die wollen nicht, dass du dort irgendwelche, ähm, äh, Dinger abstellst,
Dinger hast, reinbringst, und nicht, nichts, nicht wieder mit rausnimmst.
Bewerb dich bei Crytek, die suchen vier Leute bei Crysis 4, also mal ganz davon abgesehen,
ähm, dass ich absolut keinen Bock hätte, in der Gaming-Industrie zu arbeiten, äh,
bin ich schlicht und ergreifend, hab ich auch nicht genug Plan, um an Crysis mitentwickeln
zu können.
Ich hab von Spielerentwicklung keine Ahnung, ich hab von der CryEngine keine Ahnung, ähm,
ich hab von dem, was die dort brauchen, wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil, keine Ahnung, also ich
glaube nicht, dass ich da an Crysis großartig mitwirken könnte, außer will ich absolut
nicht in die Spielerentwicklung.
Ja, ich wusste, steht der hier überhaupt, steht der hier vielleicht drin, D6, wat, nein.
Ach, hier ist der offizielle Eingang vielleicht, keine Ahnung, aber D6 ist hier nebenan, in
der Hanover Landstraße, ja, ähm, ich wusste da, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet
habe, paar Mal rein, das ist wirklich cool zu sehen, mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich
noch viel krasser als damals, aber da ist durchaus, äh, ordentlich viel Netzwerkpower
zu finden.
Was spricht, äh, was spricht dagegen in der Spielerentwicklung, ähm, ich hab keine
Ahnung von Spielerentwicklung, oder du meinst, warum ich es auch nicht machen möchte, ich
möchte es nicht machen, weil das, von alledem, was man lesen kann, hört und, äh, so mitbekommt,
richtig miese Arbeitsbedingungen sind.
Manchmal spiele ich auch was, zum größten Teil mache ich aber weder Gaming noch Just-Chatting,
zum größten Teil machen wir absoluten 5-Hat-Hi-IQ-Content, da machen wir zum Beispiel Sachen wie, ähm,
Sachen programmieren, Sachen programmieren, Windows-Package-Manager angucken, sinnlose
Amazon-Einkaufs-Streams, C++, das müsste ich eigentlich, das müsste ich eigentlich aus
meiner History löschen, nicht dass noch jemand denkt, ich mach gerne C++ Sachen, ab und zu
spielen wir auch mal Sachen wie, verkackte Battlefield 2042 DLCs, und Zeug, genau, ja,
hab ich gesehen, das ist übelst abgedreht, ich hab so eine Videofahrt gesehen mit Musik
drunter, die ich wahrscheinlich aufgrund der Musik jetzt nicht anmachen kann im Stream,
richtig abgedreht, also, ähnlich, so wie ich es erwarten würde, wenn sich einer was
eingeschmissen hat davor, das stimmt auch, das stimmt auch, aber wie gesagt, ich würde
nicht, ich würde nicht in die Spieleentwicklung gehen, ja, die Welt ist klein, wobei ich glaube,
es kommen hier bestimmt noch mehr Leute aus Hanau, Frankfurt und Umgebung, so, machen
wir Frankfurt wieder dicht, genug, Goethe-Straße-Louis-Vitor-Store-Zahl-die-Kollektion-Bar-Fick-auf-Sponsor,
übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind, jetzt wo ich, jetzt, jetzt wo ich schon mal das
Haftbefehl Zitat bringe, ja, zeige ich euch auch mal die Goethe-Straße, und, das stimmt
sogar, was er sagt, da ist tatsächlich ein Louis-Vitor-Store, ob man auf Sponsor ficken
muss, ist was anderes, aber, hier ist die Goethe-Straße, High-End-Shopping-Street-die-Goethe-Straße-Louis-Vitor-Store,
da ist der Gucci-Store, und der Cartier-Store, und, und irgendwo auch der Louis-Vitor-Store,
und Hermes-Frankfurt ist natürlich auch da, der hat aber mit dem Paket-Dings nichts zu
tun, so, und es ist auch am Main, ja, der Main ist lang, genau, Dezix, es gibt verschiedene,
es gibt verschiedene Rechenzentren, die zum Dezix gehören, aber das, wie gesagt, das
an der Hannover-Landstraße ist das größte in Europa, und, wenn nicht eines der größten
der Welt, Geo-Gesser, ne, bin ich zu schlecht, ich find ja noch nicht mal in Frankfurt, wo
die Straßen sind, ne, Geo-Gesser bin ich komplett verloren, ich hab letztens ein Geo-Gesser-Speedrun
gesehen, total abgedrehtes Zeug, der Typ, der kam irgendwo in Ägypten oder so raus,
und hat sich Schilder angeguckt, sagt, ah, ich bin in Ägypten, hat sich umgedreht, hat
irgendwie drei Palmen gesehen, hat gesagt, aha, ich bin hier an der Kreuzung, und dann
ist ihm aufgefallen noch ein bisschen weiter, ah, die Autos sehen so und so aus, ah, ich
bin da, und irgendwie klickt er auf die Karte und ist dann irgendwie nur, was weiß ich,
drei Kilometer davon entfernt, wo er steht, also die Leute sind wirklich Massive-High-IQ,
die Geo-Gesser-Speedrunner, und wer das nicht kennt, ja, man kann Geo-Gesser-Speedrun, man
kann alles Speedrun, wo ich ja gut bin im Speedrun, ist Speedrun fürs Stream beenden,
glaub, da bin ich so mit der Schnellste auf Twitch, ah, Mann, ja, was gucken wir uns
denn jetzt an, ähm, weil, wie gesagt, ich bin heute nicht angekommen, um irgendwelche
großartigen Sachen zu machen, ich bin viel zu kaputt, das ganze Hin und Her-Gefahre vor
gestern der Zahnarzt, nee, gestern der Zahnarzt, und heute das ganze Hin und Her-Gefahre, da
ist man mit 38 schon am Limit, wobei ich bin auch nicht mal 38, fast, da ist man mit fast
38 schon am Limit, ja, die Leute, also die Geo-Gesser-Speedrunner, die lernen nicht
alles auswendig, die lernen halt so Merkmale, so, ist das in Chirilisch, oder ist das in
Arabisch, oder ist das in Deutsch, oder ist das in, ja, die gucken sich die Schriftzeichen
an, die gucken sich Verkehrsschilder an und solche Geschichten, also, und dann reimen
sie sich irgendwie zusammen, wo sie sind, es ist sicherlich vieles auswendig gelernt,
aber es ist auch viel, so, so kombinieren im Kopf für Geo-Gesser-Speedrun.
Wird Zeit für 100% Homeoffice, ja, nächste Woche, ähm, muss ich, muss ich noch was drauf
schreiben, fällt mir gerade drauf, nächste Woche habe ich ersten Termin, was neuen Job
angeht, Teams-Meeting, wobei das viel schneller war, als ich das eigentlich geplant habe,
bzw. vermutet habe, dass sich da was ergibt, und ich bin ja aktuell nur am gucken, ich
will ja gar nicht unbedingt wechseln, ich habe das jetzt aber zum Anlass genommen mit
Homeoffice einfach mal, einfach mal zu gucken, und witzigerweise haben sich sechs Leute bei
mir gemeldet, sogar auf Twitter einer, per Mail, die meisten davon wollten mich bloß
aufmerksam machen, hier guck mal bei uns, gibt's was, aber es waren auch mehrere Anfragen
dabei, so nach dem Motto, willst du nicht zu uns, what the fuck, ja, geht ja, geht ja,
also, hätte ich nicht gedacht, das einfach nur mal, weil ich mich im Stream ein bisschen
drüber auslasse, da ich die Leute per Mail an Start komme, aber, ja, ich beschwer mich
da nicht drüber.
Ja, kannst du dir überlegen, wenn du mich geschaut hast in der Schule, und ich bin jetzt
38, ist ganz einfach, dann warst du damals einer der zwölfjährigen, dreizehnjährigen
Call of Duty Kinder, und heute bist du 25.
Stimmt's, sag ich doch, sag ich doch, ja, nicht nur du, nicht nur du, wahrscheinlich
der halbe Chat, der von damals da ist, wobei ich ja sagen muss, ich bin echt wirklich sehr
froh, wie sich das auf YouTube entwickelt hat, ich mach ja schon, also, ich hab am Anfang
meinen Call of Duty Gedöns gemacht, ja, so, danach ein bisschen Battlefield Gedöns, und
dann hab ich gefühlt vier Jahre fast nix gemacht, und die letzten, ja, sagen wir mal,
so die letzten zwei, zweieinhalb Jahre, mach ich wieder mehr, und es sind so viele Leute
noch am Start, und so viele Leute, die schreiben, Max, ich hab jetzt auch Fachinformatik gelernt
oder ich studier grad Informatik, irgendwas in der Richtung, so nach dem Motto, ich wär
nie auf die Idee gekommen, ohne dass ich deine Videos geguckt hätte, und es sind sau viele
Leute heute noch da, ja, es ist natürlich langsamer als damals, was ich Subscriber kriege,
aber es geht immer noch aufwärts, also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich 300k bis
Ende des Jahres schaffe, also aktuell mach ich ein bisschen was über tausend, bisschen
was, über tausend, irgendwie tausend, 500 Subs, war das jetzt, war das jetzt glaub ich
im letzten Monat, das wird glaub ich knapp mit 300.000, das Toilettenvideo, ja das Toilettenvideo
hat er auch fast wieder gesehen, und das Schneestellvideo, ja, und das coole ist, ich mach jetzt ja
nicht mehr, was weiß ich, Call of Duty Headset-Tipps oder sowas, sondern ganz andere Sachen, und
die Leute sind noch da, es sind natürlich auch viele neue dazugekommen, und was ich
ja auch viel cooler finde ist, dass viele Leute auf Twitch am Start sind, die den Twitch-Channel
nicht über YouTube gefunden haben, sondern den Twitch-Channel komischerweise über Twitch
selber, weil sie in der Kategorie geguckt haben oder sonst was, und auf einmal waren
sie dann im Chat und haben gesagt, Max, ich kenn dich doch noch von YouTube von vor 5
Jahren.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, weil das wird ja immer oft gefragt, das ist übrigens
auch der Grund, warum ich auf Twitch nicht MaxFPS heiße, weil ich hab den Channel erstellt,
ich hab übrigens MaxFPS als Name gesichert auf Twitch, also ich könnte mich umbenennen,
hab ich aber eigentlich gar nicht vor, ich hab mir den Channel erstellt, ohne die Absichten
selbst zu streamen und irgendwann hab ich halt gedacht, weißt was, ich fang jetzt auch
mit an, aber mir war es von Anfang an, gerade weil ich da auch nicht an YouTube so viel
gemacht hab, mir war das von Anfang an gar nicht so recht, dass mich die Leute so direkt
von YouTube finden, weil es gibt halt auf YouTube halt viele nervigen Leute, wenn man eins sagen
muss Leute, wenn ich sagen würde, was ist der Durchschnitts-IQ oder was meint ihr, welche
Plattform hat den höheren Durchschnitts-IQ, YouTube oder Twitch, Twitch, eindeutig, eindeutig
Twitch, ich mein der Chat bei mir ist natürlich nochmal Next Level High IQ, Twitch, ohne Scheiß,
Twitch ist so viel besser von Idioten, klar es gibt auch viele Deppen auf Twitch, aber
es gibt auf YouTube so viele Leute, die einfach nur, weiß ich nicht, so abgrundtief dumm sind,
die es gar nicht mal böse meinen, die aber einfach nur dumm und kurzsichtig und dämlich
sind ja, und immer wenn ich solche Leute in den Comments finde auf YouTube bei mir unter
den Videos, dann dreh ich immer am Rat, mittlerweile kann ich es ja halbwegs ignorieren, aber ich
hab mich, ich hab Glück, bei mir auf dem Channel, auch auf YouTube sind ja zu 95% schlaue oder
zumindest angenehme Leute ja, exakt, genau so was ja, manche haben es hier schon als
Meme-Chat-Command geschafft, danke für die Subs Leute, ja, übrigens wisst ihr was ich
mich frage, welcher UI Designer, und ich mein, Moment das ist noch das Falsche, vielleicht
kriegst du den Firefox, hä, warum hab ich noch nicht das alte Design, warum hab ich
noch, guck mal, ich hab noch nicht das neue Design, Sekunde, mal kurz, Private Window,
darf nicht, ich weiß nicht, anscheinend hab ich hier noch nicht das neue Design, ich
wollt mich nämlich grade beschweren über das neue YouTube Design, welcher UI Designer
allen Ernstes gedacht hat, das wäre eine gute Idee, guck mal mal, vielleicht ist es
ja mit Chrome so, der Umut hat uns abgekriegt, Pog, hast du ihm den direkt gegiftet oder
war das Zufall, der hat ihn auf jeden Fall verdient, der ist, hier, da ist es doch, der
ist nämlich auch öfters am Start, guck mal, also welcher UI Designer hat sich gedacht,
das ist eine gute Idee, das sieht einfach nur total hässlich aus, so, so gestaucht
und so unnütz, unübersichtlich, und wenn ihr eingeloggt seid, habt ihr noch mehr Buttons,
da habt ihr noch die Buttons für Clip anlegen, äh, teilen und alles, was noch, was noch
mal vier Buttons hier unten drunter, also wer hat sich bei den YouTube Design, ich
meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir sollten davon ausgehen, wir sollten davon ausgehen,
dass YouTube das Geld und die Experten hat, äh, nee, Schwachsensatz, dass YouTube das
Geld und das Know-How hat, ähm, und wahrscheinlich, theoretisch zumindest, die besten mit, die
besten UI Designer der Welt beschäftigen könnte und die besten Frontend Entwickler
der Welt beschäftigen könnte, und ich weiß nicht, also wenn die weltbesten UI Designer
und Frontend Entwickler sowas fabrizieren, da gibt's ja nur zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder
wir sind alle zu dumm, die Genialität dieses Designs zu verstehen, oder die sind massive
overbezahlt, ja, ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll, du hast die Kommentare hier unten
drunter und dann kannst du die Kommentare noch mal rechts einblenden, das ist ja, ok,
ich verstehe das, wenn man das so auf Tablets machen will oder meinetwegen auf Smartphones
machen will im Querformat, ok, aber YouTube hat doch sicherlich schon mal was von gehört,
dass man Geräte, also so responsive, dass man seine Webseite so responsive designen kann,
also sprich, dass man die Webseite für unterschiedliche Geräte, bzw. für unterschiedliche Displaygrößen
unterschiedlich aussehen lassen kann, äh, nee, die 100% der Webseite ist so, es sieht
aber noch beschissener aus auf 100%, guckt euch das mal an, the fuck, das sieht jetzt
nicht besser aus, oder, und wie gesagt, ich bin nicht eingeloggt, normalerweise kommt da
noch eine Zeile unten drunter, also das ist wirklich, für mich nicht nachvollziehbar,
was YouTube da baut, man kann sich ja bei Twitch, man kann sich ja bei Twitch auch
beschweren, aber da ist die Twitch-Webseite wirklich um Längen, um Längen besser, was
mich, wisst ihr, was mich bei Twitch immer ein bisschen nervt, ist, dass wenn einer online
ist, also sogar in dem Fall hier, so, Max ist online, dass du nicht mehr so ohne weiteres
auf die Profilbeschreibung kommst, also sprich, wenn ich jetzt zu euch sage, ja, guckt mal
mal, mir im Profil, in der Beschreibung, dann, ähm, dann steht das da, da müsst ihr
erst mal, also wenn ihr hier den Chat, Moment, erzähl ich jetzt Mist, Habis, nee, ach Quatsch,
nicht auf die Profil, nicht auf die, Schwachsinn, nicht auf die Profilbeschreibung, auf die,
äh, auf die Übersicht, da müsst ihr nämlich erst mal auf dieses Bild klicken, und dann
hast du hier erst die anderen Sachen, also, da kann man sich auch drüber beschweren,
aber das ist echt in Ordnung Twitch, und ich muss auch sagen, es wird sich viel beschwert
über Twitch, ähm, auch gerade seit der Amazon-Übernahme, aber ich muss sagen, insgesamt, finde ich,
hat sich Twitch schon zu einer guten oder besseren Plattform entwickelt, man muss aber
gucken, aus welchem Gesichtspunkt, ja, ähm, Twitch, also für mich als Zuschauer, war die
geilste Zeit auf Twitch, quasi, was war denn das so, so 2016, 17 oder so, wo, wo Speedruns
angesagt waren, und wo, wo es halt noch nicht so Mainstream war, wo halt, Leute vielleicht
tausend Zuschauer hatten, und das war mega viel, und, als die Speedrun-Events noch, ja,
nach Spaß ausgesehen haben, und nicht nervig waren, das war für mich als Zuschauer auf
Twitch die geilste Zeit, aber als Plattform, gerade für Content-Creator, hat sich Twitch
wirklich gut entwickelt, ich mein, du kannst heute, so einfach wie noch nie, ich sag nicht,
dass es einfach insgesamt ist, aber so einfach wie noch nie, als Streamer leben davon, durch
die ganze Amazon Prime-Geschichte, durch die neuen Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten, durch
Twitch als Plattform, die jetzt deutlich bekannter und akzeptierter ist als früher, die haben
auch dank Amazon Cloud-Kapazitäten jetzt deutlich weniger Probleme als früher, also Twitch hat
sich rein als Plattform schon gut entwickelt, was ich halt bei Twitch persönlich ein bisschen
angreide ist, dass sie halt ihre Regeln, ja, aber das ist bei YouTube übrigens ähnlich,
dass sie halt ihre Regeln nicht wirklich gut nachvollziehbar auslegen, ja, manche Leute
werden gebannt, du weißt nicht warum, manche Leute werden gebannt für eine Sache eine
Woche, der andere drei Tage, der andere sonst wie, bei manchen hast du das Gefühl, sie
sind komplett immun dagegen, gebannt zu werden, da gibt es dann immer die Gerüchte, so nach
dem Motto, die Twitch-Moderatoren sind mit den ganzen Poolgrills, irgendwie, was auch
immer, glaube ich nicht, ich glaube einfach, dass es bei der Auslegung ziemlich starke
Diskrepanzen gibt zwischen dem, wer was bewertet, es ist ja bei YouTube auch so, wenn du bei
YouTube ein Video hochlädst, zum Beispiel, guck mal, ich hab letztens dieses Video hier
auf YouTube hochgeladen, Virus ohne Anklicken, wo ich mich über die Sicherheitslöcke in
Windows und Word ausgelassen habe, oder ich hab ein Video gemacht zu, was hatte ich denn
sonst, ich hab einige IT-Security-Themen in letzter Zeit gemacht und es gibt genug Leute
auf YouTube, da wird solch ein Video als Hacking-Content ausgelegt und wird gesperrt und die Leute
bekommen da teilweise sogar Strikes dafür, weil es ja angeblich Hacking-Content ist,
Semper-Video kann ein Lied davon singen, Algorithmen verstehen auch und die haben noch Reichweite,
die kriegen das irgendwie wieder hingebogen, was machst du denn als etwas kleinerer Content-Creator,
stell dir mal vor, du bist ein bisschen kleinerer Content-Creator, hast 7000 Subs, machst IT-Security-Content
und ein Video von dir wird gestrikt, was machst du, du reichst Beschwerde ein, da kommt irgendein
Typ von YouTube hin, guckt sich das Video an und sagt, ne, ne, das war schon richtig,
es bleibt gesperrt, einen weiteren Versuch kannst du nicht machen, das ist so ein bisschen
wie eBay Kleinanzeigen, die mir die E-Mail geantwortet haben, ich soll mich doch fernhalten
von ihrem Marktplatz, wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat, quasi eines der frechesten Antworten,
die ich je bekommen habe per Mail, guckt euch, das müsst ihr euch mal angucken hier,
habe ich von eBay Kleinanzeigen gekriegt die Antwort, load more, ja, hier, vielen Dank für
eure Nachricht, die Anmeldung über ihr Neuzahlkonto ist nicht mehr möglich, diese Entscheidung
ist endgültig und wir bitten sie daher Abstand von unserem Marktplatz zu nehmen, weitere
Anfragen ihrerseits werden wir gerne zur Kenntnis nehmen, die ihr noch nicht mehr beantworten
habt, und wohlgemerkt, wisst ihr was ich gemacht habe, mein Vergehen war, kein eBay Kleinanzeigen
Account zu haben, ich hatte noch nie einen eBay Kleinanzeigen Account und ich wollte
letztens für einen Access Point bei eBay Kleinanzeigen mal gucken und ich wollte mich dann einloggen
bei eBay Kleinanzeigen bzw. einen Account anlegen bei eBay Kleinanzeigen und ich nehme
meine E-Mail Adresse halt, die ich auch bei eBay benutze, wobei alles okay ist auf eBay,
wobei eBay Kleinanzeigen und eBay ja nichts miteinander zu tun haben und gebe die E-Mail
Adresse ein und die sagen ihr Konto ist eingeschränkt, ich denke mir, hä, ich habe doch gar kein
Konto und dann schreibe ich an den Support eine E-Mail und frage, ich habe doch kein
Konto, warum ist mein Konto gesperrt, wie kann das sein, was ist denn da vorgefallen
und da kriege ich diese Antwort und daraufhin habe ich mir gedacht, ihr dreckigen Kackspasten
bei eBay Kleinanzeigen, ich werde euren Service nie im Leben verwenden, ich hätte mir eine,
ich weiß, dass ich mir eine Fake E-Mail Adresse machen könnte oder so, ja, ich könnte mir
eine Fake E-Mail Adresse machen, also kein Problem, aber diesen Müll will ich gar nicht
wissen was der letzte Preis ist mehr, wenn ich sowas hier bekomme, ja und so ungefähr
ist das und so ungefähr ist das auch wenn ein, genau, so ist das auch wenn einer bei
YouTube deine, dein Einspruch von Videos überprüft, der guckt sich den Kram auch nicht richtig
an, der sieht dieses Video und sagt, ho das ist, obwohl es das nicht ist, ho das muss bestimmt
Hacking Content sein, jaja, das ist gerechtfertigt, weil der hat keine Ahnung vom Inhalt und
der hat wahrscheinlich auch noch weitere 50 Videos zu Reviewen und dementsprechend hast
du als kleiner Content Creator einfach gelitten, ich könnte noch irgendjemand vom Netzwerk
anschreiben oder selbst jemand vom Support anschreiben, was auch immer, aber was machst
du als Content Creator, der vielleicht nicht Partner ist und 7500 Viewer hat, du hast einfach
gelitten, du bist, der YouTube macht da oder auch auf Twitter, wenn dein Account gesperrt
ist, bist der Sache ausgeliefert, du kannst nichts machen, sind bestimmt, bestimmt, ganz
ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass mich die Admins von der Bahn hassen, weil ich schreibe bei
meinen Twitter Posts immer dabei, dass ich nicht die Leute hinter den Accounts, sondern
die einzelnen Bahnmitarbeiter meine und ich glaube die Bahn Admins sehen es wahrscheinlich
genauso.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade bei unterschiedlichen Plattformen sind, wie gesagt, ich denke Twitch
hat sich echt gut entwickelt, trotz Amazon, manche Sachen sind halt merkwürdig und wisst
ihr was mir gerade einfällt, was ist eigentlich aus dem Twitch Ethik, ne wie heißt das Ethik
Rat, ne, wie ist das aus diesem Twitch Community Rat geworden, mit dem Reh, erinnert sich
noch jemand?
Da muss ich schon kecken, wenn ich dran denke, Alter, äh, was ist denn, was ist denn aus
dem Reh geworden?
Gibt es diesen, gibt es diesen Community, ähm, Community Rat eigentlich noch bei Twitch,
hat da irgendjemand was von gehört?
Reh?
Okay, wer nicht weiß was ich meine, wer nicht weiß was ich meine, Leute, sucht nicht danach,
es ist, es ist verstörend und ich will es jetzt auch nicht zeigen, weil ich die Person
selber nicht dissen will, sondern ich fand es einfach nur äußerst befremdlich, also
es gab mal sowas, sowas wie ein Twitch Community, Konsul, oder irgendwie so Council, das war
quasi ein Gremium aus 5 oder 6 bekannten und nicht so bekannten Streamern, die Twitch quasi
irgendwie beraten sollten bei der Auslegung ihrer Community richtigen oder sonst was, zumindest
da gab es eine Person, ich sage absichtlich Person, weil das ist ja ein ganz heikles Thema,
wie man Leute anredet, da gab es eine Person in diesem Twitch Community Council, die sich
selbst als Reh, also wirklich als, als Reh, also sowas was im Wald ist normalerweise,
Safety Council, ja genau, Council, als Reh identifiziert hat und da gab es Videos, da
saß die quasi, diese Person saß dann auf dem Sofa und hat dann so Reh, keine Ahnung,
so Reh Roleplays gemacht, das ist ganz wirr gewesen, das war ganz komisch, ich weiß nicht,
das hat mich, das hat mich doch schon ein wenig verstört, als ich das gesehen habe,
deswegen habe ich mir gerade so die Frage gestellt, was ist dann mit dem Reh passiert?
Ja, das war schon, das war schon echt bisschen, bisschen merkwürdig.
Ach tatsächlich, ok, das habe ich schon gar nicht mehr mitbekommen, ich kenne nur dieses
eine Video mit dem Reh Roleplay, das hat mich echt verstört und ich habe schon viel verstörenden
Kram im Internet gesehen und aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das bei mir hängen geblieben,
aber letztendlich, jeder soll machen, was er will, aber wer da von Videos macht und
sich Livestreamt dabei, sollte es zumindest gestatten, dass man sich nicht wundert, kennt
man vom Hauptbahnhof, also ich habe am Hauptbahnhof schon Leute gesehen, die Flieger Roleplay
haben und die Straße lang gelaufen sind als Flieger mit ausgestreckten Armen, ja das habe
ich schon erlebt, aber Leute, die als Tiere Roleplay haben, habe ich jetzt so noch nicht
gesehen.
Ok, das ist krasser Chebathe, der Typ erzählt wahrscheinlich, ok ich predicte mal, wir gucken
uns das Video nicht an, der erzählt jetzt, er hat jetzt Neo-Wim anstatt Swim oder irgendwie
sowas.
Das ist, wenn, also der Channel von dem, ich finde das echt interessant, weil das ist,
wie wenn ein hyperaktiver Let's Player Wim Tutorials macht, der Typ, ok diesmal ist gar
nicht so hektisch, aber das ist wirklich, wie wenn so ein super krass, gehypter hyperaktiver
Let's Player Wim Tutorials macht der Channel von dem Kerl, so, komm wir gucken uns jetzt
noch, in einer halben Stunde muss ich eh pennen, wir gucken uns jetzt noch den JavaScript Report
an von dieser Woche, zeig mal her, bester Channel übrigens, den gucke ich sehr gerne,
ThePyreShip, der macht immer ziemlich gut, es sind ja keine Tutorials, der macht immer
ziemlich gut gestaltete Videos in Richtung Webentwicklung und die sind immer kurz und
knackig, die gucke ich gerne, kann man sich echt geben.
Natürlich, natürlich, ja, mit Sicherheit, der kann nix anderes gemeint haben, der muss
sich auf JavaScript bezogen haben, ist logisch, hat er sogar Einstein gesagt, man soll Node.js
verwenden und by the way, soll ich euch mal verraten, was auch schnell ist, könnt einfach
eine andere Programmiersprache fürs Backend nehmen als JavaScript, die ist in der Regel
auch schnell, aber ja C++, aber C++ hat andere Probleme, ok, ich lass dir das, C++ ist schnell,
zumindest beim Ausführen, beim Entwickeln weniger, aber man kann einfach im Backend
etwas anderes als JavaScript nehmen, übrigens danke für die ganzen Subs, ich hab bestimmt
den einen oder anderen übersehen, Flix, danke für den Zappen.
It's good.
oder im Falle von C++ 30 Header-Files mit Definitionen, die sich selbst widersprechen.
und es wird dich irgendwo nehmen, wo du gehen willst.
Jetzt, dass wir fertig sind mit dieser verrückten Analyse,
Lass uns darüber reden, was BUNN speziell macht.
Also ihr müsst zugeben, es hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, oder?
Okay, weiter.
Die Webkit JavaScript ist
also keine Programmiersprache ist abgedreht genug, dass da irgendeine JavaScript-Gedünstrinne macht.
Okay, Webpack ist ja auch wirklich menschenverachtend.
Wisst ihr was durchaus sein kann?
Wenn es dann mal alle Features von V8 und Node hat, ist es genauso langsam.
Das ist ja das, was ich am Anfang immer bei Deno mir gedacht habe.
Warum sollte man Deno verwenden, wenn man nicht auf das NPM-Package-Ökosystem zurückgreifen kann?
Mittlerweile geht es ja bei Deno auch irgendwie, habe ich gelesen.
Aber das ist natürlich ein kluger Schachzug, weil es gibt so viele NPM-Packages.
Also ich würde sagen, JavaScript hat mittlerweile das größte Library-Ekosystem von allen Sprachen.
Normalerweise wollte ich jetzt so etwas sagen wie face-roll über die Tastatur, aber wenn du face-rolls über die Tastatur,
kommt auf jeden Fall nicht so was Strukturiertes raus wie a1, b2, c3.
2c3. Das muss schon Absicht gewesen sein. Es gab übrigens wieder ein NPM Supply Chain Angriff
vor zwei Tagen oder so. Irgendwelche Packages für, diesmal waren es, glaube ich, Icons, haben
irgendwelche Tracking Software ausgeliefert. Das ist ja mittlerweile schon normal bei NPM.
Ja, ich dachte es ist ja schon dauerhaft. No Cap oder No Cap? Aber ganz ehrlich,
das JavaScript Ökosystem mag umfangreich und besser ausgestattet sein als die meisten
oder fast alle anderen Programmiersprachen. Sie übertreiben es aber maßlos. Ich meine,
in welcher anderen Programmiersprache brauchst du Packages IsOdd und IsEven? Es gibt sogar
das Packages IsIsOdd oder IsEven. Ich meine, wenn es nur in Programmiersprachen eingebaute
Konstrukte geben würde, um festzustellen, ob eine Zahl gleich oder un- äh nicht gleich oder un-
gleich, gerade oder ungerade ist. Nachdem das noch nie jemand erfunden hat in Programmiersprachen,
braucht man dann natürlich Packages für. Und man muss sich das mal angucken. Es gibt tatsächlich
Leute, die haben das instand. Guck mal, 407.000 Weekly Downloads IsOdd, IsEven. Der Source Code
ist nur fünf Zeilen lang oder so. Ja, ich habe das mal ausprobiert. Der Source Code ist irgendwie
hier. Das ist alles. Dafür braucht man jetzt dieses tolle Node-Modul. Im Endeffekt, das hier
ist das, was er macht. Also, man weiß es nicht. Es ist JavaScript. JavaScript ist alles möglich.
In JavaScript ist möglich, dass not a number not a number ist. Es gibt wahrscheinlich so gut
wie alles in dieser Richtung in JavaScript. Moment. NPM IsEven. Okay, lass mich raten. Okay,
ich predikte jetzt mal was. Der Code von IsEven ist nicht etwa zu gucken, ob die Zahl Even ist,
sondern eine Dependency zu haben auf IsOdd und dann not davor zu schreiben. Ich wusste es,
Leute. Seriously. Alter JavaScript, ich fasse es nicht. Das ist so abgefuckt teilweise. Schau
auf die Downloads. Na ja, 200.000 Weekly Downloads. Das ist nicht mein Ernst,
das ist dem sein Ernst. Hat er Unit-Tests für? Wahrscheinlich hat er sogar Unit-Tests für IsOdd,
ist Even. Hochkomplexe Tests werden das sein. Na gut, so blöd ist das tatsächlich gar nicht.
Zu gucken, ob man 012 abfackeln kann. Ja, okay. So sieht es im JavaScript Ökosystem aus. Was
will denn Level Cap von uns wieder? Battlefield 1. Sagen wir mal, wie oft will Level Cap das
bitteschön noch machen? Bei jedem noch so kleinen Popel-Update von Battlefield schreibt er Massive
Update. Massive Update leaked. Huge changes. Huge, big update. Und im Endeffekt haben sie
ein neues Red Dot für sie reingemacht oder so. Major. Ich will das schon gar nicht mehr gucken,
weil es einfach so krasser Chip-Aid ist. Ich gucke mir ganz gerne sonntags diese Weekly Recaps von
Level Cap an. Das ist ja in Ordnung. Aber der Rest ist teilweise echt... Aber wisst ihr,
was man daran sieht? Und das sollte DICE zur Kenntnis nehmen. Man sieht daran, dass sich Leute auch
nach diesem Hyper-Reinfall Battlefield 2042 immer noch für Battlefield interessieren. Das sollte
DICE zur Kenntnis nehmen und was Gutes draus machen. Machen sie nicht. Ich meine, das ist DICE. Wer
erwartet ernsthaft, dass da noch was kommt. Aber das sollten sie besser. Werden sie aber nicht machen.
Weil DICE nichts mehr auf die Reihe kriegt. Ja, das ist nichts Neues Leute. Das stimmt,
das ist eine Fork-Bomb. Das ist nichts Neues. Wenn ihr das auf eine Linux-Shell eingebt. Das
stimmt übrigens nicht so ganz, dass euer Computer crasht, aber der friert ein. Es sei denn, es sind
ordentliche Limits gesetzt, was einige Distributionen mittlerweile standardmäßig machen heutzutage. Ja,
also wenn ihr das 1 zu 1 so unter Linux in die Kommandozeile eintippt, dann wird nach ein paar
Sekunden euer Rechner immer langsamer und irgendwann freezen. ZSR Bash egal? Ich glaube schon, ja. Es
geht sogar in SH. Es geht sogar in einer ganz normalen Shell. Ja, übrigens, ich kann euch
erklären, wie das funktioniert. Da brauchen wir das Video nicht zu. Das ist eine Fork-Bomb. Das
heißt, Fisch nee und Fisch nicht, weil Fisch ist keine POSIX-kompatible Shell, die das unterstützt.
Also es ist eigentlich ganz simpel. Das ist nur bisschen obfuscated. Das ist eine Fork-Bomb. Das
bedeutet, dieses Programm startet sich einfach sau oft selbst. Also das Programm ruft sich
sau oft selbst auf und endlich oft mehrfach selbst auf. Also das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Doppelpunkt, Klammer auf, Klammer zu, ist eine Funktionsdefinition in Bash. Nur dass in Bash
Doppelpunkt ein gültiger Funktionsname ist. Also das hier ist die Funktion Doppelpunkt. So,
danach hier Funktionsbody, wie in jeder anderen Programmiersprache auch. Funktionsbody,
geschweifte Klammer auf, geschweifte Klammer zu. Und in diesem Body ruft er die Funktion,
die hier definiert wurde, auf und dann nochmal auf im Hintergrund. Also sprich,
der startet sich hier drinnen zweimal neu. Bei dem und bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht ganz
sicher. Ich glaube, das und ist dafür da, dass es, also das Pipe, das ist ja kein und,
das ist ja ein Pipe. Ich glaube, das ist dafür da, dass der nicht wartet, bis das erste Command
fertig ist. Also bei dem Pipe bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher. Aber ich glaube, das ist, dass er
das zweite schon ausführt, wenn das erste noch läuft und dann im Hintergrund. Also dieses Programm
wird nichts anderes machen, außer sich selbst aufrufen doppelt. Also für jeden Aufruf startet
es sich doppelt selbst im Hintergrund, dass es nicht blockiert. Wie reagiert WSL auf eine Forkbombe?
Ich vermute mal, es wird irgendwann das Terminal abkacken oder aber Windows freezen. Ich weiß
nicht, was WSL alles für Rechte hat, ob WSL das da auch prozess- und ramtechnisch voll machen
darf. Ja, und es passiert folgendermaßen. Ich kann euch das übrigens zeigen, wenn ihr mir das
nicht glaubt. Wir können meine Linux-VM aufmachen. Es kann aber sein, dass ich Limits gesetzt habe
und es bei mir in der VM gar nicht funktioniert. Aber machen wir mal, machen wir mal. Ich mache
mal meine VM an. Ich meine, die VM können wir crashen, da passiert nichts. Ne, in WSL teste ich
das nächste höchste in der VM. Ja, und das ist das, was passiert. Das heißt, das macht einfach euren
Rechner voll mit sich selbst. Ich habe noch eine Windows-VM, ja, aber ich habe jetzt keinen, ich
habe jetzt keinen Bock, Windows-VM zu updaten und sowas. Also machen wir mal die Forkbombe,
bauen wir das einfach mal nach. Aber wie gesagt, es kann sein, dass es nicht funktioniert, weil ich
Limits gesetzt habe. Also das crasht, wenn du Limits gesetzt hast. Also du kannst, du kannst
der Sache vorbeugen, indem du einfach Limits setzt, wie viele Prozesse und Subprozesse gestartet
werden dürfen. Warum muss das Ganze am Ende noch mal die Doppelpunkt-Funktion, ach ja, damit es
zum ersten Mal gestartet wird? Also das hier ist ja nur die, nur die Definition der Funktion und das
hier ist, dass es initial gestartet wird. Also, na, wie funktioniert das jetzt? Doppelpunkt, Klammer auf,
Klammer zu, Schleifen, Body, Doppelpunkt, Pipe. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob mein Leerzeichen machen
darf. Pipe, Backdings und dann, weil, muss man Semikolon machen? Ne, Dings, Semikolon, Doppelpunkt.
Vielleicht muss man es auch zusammen schreiben. So, mal mal die Auslastung da oben. Okay, das geht
nicht, muss man wahrscheinlich zusammenschreiben.
Habe ich vertippt? Das war eigentlich gut so, oder?
Oh, mein Rechner hängt. Leute, der ist schon, der ist schon gefriest. Der macht nichts mehr.
Vorbei. Guck mal, mein Taskmanager. Guck mal, hier 100%, RAM ist auch voll. Guck mal, hier 100%
Performance. Und die vor allem ist, die vor allem ist komplett am abkacken. Hier, 16GB RAM. Ah, okay, jetzt ist er
abgekackt. Jetzt ist vorbei. Guck, jetzt ist auch, mein RAM ist voll, RAM ist voll und Prozesse sind
wahrscheinlich voll und alles. Wenn ich Glück habe, kann ich es irgendwie noch Control-C'en, aber
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal mehr das. Wenn ich Glück habe, kriege ich es mit ganz viel Control-C
Gespamme wieder abgebrochen. Vielleicht habe ich Glück und kann die Teamwork Session zumachen.
Vielleicht kann ich die Teamwork Session killen. Gucken wir mal. Da muss jetzt hier die Ressourcen
erstmal wieder aufräumen. Aha, ich habe es geschafft zu schließen. Doch, oh oh. Okay, es ist, es ist noch
ein bisschen, oh fuck, Alter. Kannste knicken, Alter. Also, die Kiste ist im Arsch. Ich habe
gehofft, dass das vielleicht aufhört, wenn ich das T-Max schließe, aber kannste vergessen. Also,
im Prinzip, im Prinzip kann ich jetzt nur, nee, kannst du, kannst du komplett kicken,
komplett knicken. Vorbei. Deswegen setzt man ordentliche Limits und dann passiert so was nicht.
Reset, bam. Ja, ich konnte ja nichts mehr aufrufen. Ja. Nee, ich zeig nicht, wie man Limits setzt.
Jetzt ins Bett geh gleich. Ich wollte das bloß mal zeigen, weil sich sicherlich
einige gefragt haben, was soll das sein. Nee, ich mache das jetzt auch nicht in der Windows 11. Wie
gesagt, ich gehe jetzt gleich pennen. Boah, hier ist wieder mega warm, Alter. Irgendwie 27 Grad.
Also, ich mache noch mal schnell die Klimaanlage an. Bisschen, bisschen Strom verbrauchen für die
Nacht. Ja, jetzt habt ihr auch gelernt, was eine Forkbomb ist. Siehste, wie der Educational Stream.
Time Zones. Time Zones ist eines der grausamsten Erfindungen der Menschheitsgeschichte.
Time Zones und Time Zone Libraries. Das kann ich nicht empfehlen. Das ist meistens
viel zu energiehungrig, als dass sich das lohnt. Kann man aber machen. Also in C++ ist alles
Woodface. Ja, aber Time Zone noch schlimmer. Ich mittlerweile auch, wobei ich immer noch nicht
sicher bin, ob ich damit auf Dauer glücklich werde. Es kann durchaus sein, dass ich wieder
ganz normal Ubuntu Server verwende und drei Docker-Compose-Files hinschmeiße und gut ist.
Nee, du hast ein GUI. Du hast ein ordentliches Webinterface und du hast relativ viele Plugins,
die unter der Haube meistens irgendwelche Docker-Container sind, mit bisschen PHP-Frontenzeug,
die sich halt integrieren. Also vom Gesamtansatz her ist das, wenn du nicht gerade ein Synology
NAS kaufen willst, so das integrierteste, was man sich so bauen kann, beziehungsweise das,
wo die meisten Leute sagen würden, dass das von der Bedienung her ganz gut ist. Aber nachdem
ich eigentlich eher Kommando-Zeilen-Rk-Man bin als Webinterface-Clicker, ist es jetzt nicht so,
dass ich sage, das muss unbedingt sein. Ich erkenne die Vorteile schon an, gerade dass sie
es einfach machen mit SSD-Caches und auch dem automatischen Moven, sodass du jetzt nicht
irgendwie super teures ZFS-Rate bauen musst oder sowas. Also es hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich so komplett damit glücklich werde. So Docker-Compose-Files für
einfache Sachen daheim haben auch ihren Charme, jetzt wo Compose in Docker eingebaut ist. Na,
Proxmox sind die Schwerpunkte ganz klar woanders. Proxmox möchte ein, sagen wir so, Home- und
Enterprise-Virtualisierungssystem sein und Unraid will eher so eine Art Synergy-Nass sein. Es hat
Überschneidungen, aber das ist komplett andere Richtung. Ja, das ist Wim-Plugin für Firefox,
aber nachdem ich aufgehört habe, schon vor einigen Jahren Hardcore-Wim-User zu sein,
habe ich solche Dinger nicht mehr am Start. Nee, nee, nee, nee, ist es nicht. Der Docker-Teil
ist ganz klein, ganz kleiner Teil davon. Unraid ist eigentlich ein Web-Interface zum Konfigurieren
von einem Nass. Ja, du kannst deine Festplatten zu einem, ich nenne es mal Raid, es ist kein
klassisches Raid, du kannst deine Festplatten zu einem Raid zusammenfassen, du kannst Backup-Plattens
reinhängen, du kannst der SSD-Cache hinzufügen. Ja, mittlerweile können sie halt auch noch so
Sachen wie Synergy auch kann, VMs verwalten, Docker-Container verwalten und es gibt halt
relativ viele Community-Addons, die das ganz gut machen. Letztendlich, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass ich vielleicht doch einfach wieder auf den Ubuntu-Server umschwenke. Und bevor mich jetzt
einer fragt, warum Ubuntu und Can-Debian, das ist wurscht, nimmt sich nichts. Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich ist Debian sogar die sinnvollere Wahl. Ich bin aber vor ein paar Jahren bei Ubuntu
Server hängen geblieben und es macht bisher alles, was ich will. Zumal es ist ja eigentlich ein Debian.
Das einzige, was die bei Ubuntu dazu machen, ist, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, nervig. Die haben ihre
YAML-Konfiguration für Netzwerkkarten, wo ich mir denke, wer zum Teufel wollte jemals eine
YAML-Konfig für Netzwerke haben. Dann haben sie so Sachen wie Snap, was auch kein Mensch braucht.
Der einzige Vorteil von Ubuntu ist tatsächlich die LTS-Version bzw. die jährlichen Releases,
oder die halbjährlichen Releases sind es ja eigentlich, versus Debian, was schon alt outdated ist,
wenn sie rauskommt. Also es hat schon seine Vorteile, aber so Sachen wie YAML-Konfig für
Netzwerk oder Snap oder sowas, wie das, was Ubuntu jetzt ja auch macht, ist, wenn du unter
Ubuntu Firefox und Chrome installierst, ist es unter der Haube irgendeinen Snap-Container. Das
ist richtig dummer Blödsinn. Ultra nervig. Snap ist einfach nur Paynes-Champ. Letztens hat
auch mein Ubuntu, was ich habe, ich habe Ubuntu vor allem, von der ich Homeoffice-Sachen mache
manchmal, hat mich genervt, hat gesagt, ich muss mein Firefox neu starten, ansonsten wird
in 27 Tagen automatisch neu gestartet. Das sind ja fast Microsoft-Praktiken da. Gut,
bei Microsoft ist es, wir starten es jetzt neu, ob du willst oder nicht, bei Ubuntu sind es
wegen 27 Tage, aber das soll mein Betriebssystem bitte nicht für mich entscheiden, wann ich mein
Browser neu starte. Deswegen Leute auf dem Desktop, ihr wisst's und ich sage es jetzt
nochmal, Arch by the way. Eins einzig wahre. Wer richtig echter Linux-Hackerman sein möchte,
Arch auf dem Desktop. Oder, was ich mir auch gefallen lasse, wenn ich Arch by the way,
dann wenigstens Gentoo. Und wenn du dann eine Mail kriegst, mit einem Word-Dokument als Anhang,
was ja teilweise leider immer noch passiert, dann musst du erst mal 45 Minuten Open Office
kompilieren. Aber gut, das ist dann halt unter Gentoo so. Nee, Arch by the way. Manjaro ist
auch kein Arch. Arch Linux, das Original muss es sein. Nur so kann man Arch by the way.
Slackware. Unraid, wo wir es gerade davon an, Unraid ist die einzige, nicht die einzige,
ist das einzige Produkt, was ich kenne, was auf Slackware aufsetzt. Ich kenne niemand,
der Slackware verwendet. Ich kenne nichts, was auf Slackware aufsetzt. Also da ist Unraid
wirklich speziell. Slackware, also die Distribution selbst ist uralt, von wann sie gegründet
wurde. Slackware selbst ist auch nicht irgendwie bedeutend älter als irgendwie ein Debian
Stable oder so. Ich würde sogar sagen eher neuer. Nein, dann Susie ist nicht Slackware.
Das siehst du schon daran, dass Susie irgendwie RPM basiert ist und Slackware ist. Ich glaube
bei Slackware sind alles TGZ Files. Ja, es gab auch mal Endlinux, wo man Linux unter
Windows laufen lassen konnte vor WSL. Aber WSL hat es halt offiziell bei Microsoft gemacht.
Was ist Mini-DNF? DNF ist der Package Manager von CentOS bzw. von RedHat oder Fedora. Das,
was mal yum gewesen ist. Aber was ist Mini-DNF? Was ist Mini-DNF? Ah ja, hier alles klar.
APK ist Alpine Linux. Aha. Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, der Unterschied zwischen
yum, apt und Pacman sind einfach Welten. Pacman ist mit Abstand mein Lieblings Package Manager
bzw. irgendeinen Aufsatz für User Repos. Also Package Management ist unter Arch Linux
einfach das beste was es gibt. Update vom System. Update läuft. Fertig. Und es geht
übrigens noch viel schneller. Ich könnte meine Updates noch parallelisieren. Der kann
parallel downloaden, da muss es gar nicht nacheinander downloaden. Der lädt schon runter. Jetzt
ungefähr wäre apt soweit und würde anfangen. Und in 10 Sekunden würde yum anfangen mit
Paket Updates. Da ist der schon durch quasi. Also da kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren.
Package Management finde ich unter Arch mit Abstand am besten. Apt ist auch noch okay,
aber yum bzw. DNF oder... Was ist denn bei Susi? Was ist denn bei Susi? Super. Super.
Super ist es bei Susi gell. Super. Kann doch keiner mehr aussprechen. Super. Genau. Super
oder... Wie hieß dieses Susi Config Tool? Just gab es ja auch noch. Ne Susi ist wirklich
was da mache ich einen ganz großen Bogen drin. Kollege bei mir auf der Arbeit hat Susi. Ich
verstehe nicht, was ihn da geritten hat. Oder reitet, weil der installiert sich immer wieder
Susis. Ich habe auch die Übersicht verloren, wem Susi mittlerweile gehört. Selbst ja muss.
Was anderes als Selbst das kann ich mir nicht erklären. Das stimmt. Ich habe sogar noch
auch Susi Linux CDs. Die blauen. Ich habe noch welche. Susi Linux 4 war damals so blau.
Personal Edition. Das waren blaue CDs. Professional Edition. Das waren rote CDs. Du hast eine Susi
Linux Kappe auch nicht schlecht. Doch. Aber oft würde ich es nicht nennen. Gelegentlich.
Also im Enterprise Umfeld gibt es so zwei Lager würde ich sagen. Es gibt das Debian
Lager. Beziehungsweise das Ubuntu Lager. Und es gibt das Red Hat CentOS Lager. Und ab
und zu vereinzelt gibt es auch noch Susi. Meistens wird Susi. Zumindest dort wo ich
das erlebt habe ist. Meistens wird Susi dort verwendet wo irgendein Produkt laufen soll.
Wo der Hersteller halt Support nur unter Susi leistet. Zum Beispiel wir hatten mal eine
Software für die Telefonanlage. Die Software für irgendeine Telefonanlage. Das musste
Susi sein weil der Support nur benutzt war für diese Software wenn es unter Susi lief.
Ansonsten hat keiner freiwillig Susi installiert. Ansonsten ist es entweder Debian. Debian
ist würde ich sagen. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht. Mein Bauchgefühl würde
ich sagen Debian ist mit das verbreitetste Linux auf Servern. Und im Enterprise Umfeld
für alle die im Zweifelsfall auch mal sagen wollen. Ja wir möchten ein Support Ticket
aufmachen. Die haben dann entweder Ubuntu oder Red Hat oder eben die freie Variante
wie CentOS aber CentOS gibt es ja in der Form auch nicht mehr. Also wir haben auf der Arbeit
zum größten Teil CentOS oder hatten wir sind mittlerweile eher auf dem Ubuntu Trip also
neue Kisten und alte Kisten sollen umgezogen werden auf Ubuntu. Bin ich übrigens froh
hätte ich schon vor Jahren gerne so gehabt. Und wir haben ein paar Red Hat Support Lizenzen
Verträge und wir machen es halt so wenn irgendeine Kiste mit CentOS Probleme hat war es halt
zufälligerweise die Red Hat Kiste die Probleme hatte. Also es sind immer diese 4 Red Hat
Kisten die Probleme haben. Die mit Support halt. Damit man Tickets aufmachen kann. Aber
ich kann euch sagen ganz im Ernst egal ob Microsoft Support und ich meine nicht den
indischen Microsoft Gold Partner Support wo du erstmal ein paar Paysafe Karten einlösen
musst. Also weder der Microsoft Support noch der Oracle Support noch der Red Hat Support
sind großartig hilfreich meistens. Manchmal ja meistens ist es komplett vergebene Lebenszeit
da mit dem Support sich abzumühen. Ich mein macht man dann trotzdem irgendein Ticket auf
allein schon weil man es bezahlt aber in der Regel bringt das überhaupt nichts. Der Microsoft
Support ist meiner Meinung nach der schlechteste. Der Microsoft Support macht nämlich also ihr
müsst wissen Support Verträge gehen nicht etwa danach wann das Problem gelöst wird
sondern Support Verträge gehen nach Reaktionszeit egal mit was reagiert wird. Also sprich die
garantieren dir Reaktion innerhalb von 4 Stunden. Das heißt nicht dass irgendjemand der kompetent
ist also wenn du einen Support Vertrag mit Microsoft hast zum Beispiel. Das heißt nicht
dass irgendjemand der kompetent ist sich innerhalb von 4 Stunden dein Ticket anguckt
dein Support Ticket nein nein das bedeutet dass innerhalb von 4 Stunden jemand irgendwas
unsinniges darauf antwortet dass sie sagen können man hat darauf geantwortet. So und
Microsoft Support ist wirklich komplett komplett sinnlos das läuft in der Regel so du machst
ein Microsoft Support Ticket zum Beispiel Windows Defender verursacht seit dem letzten Update.
Ja das ist Support das ist wahnsinnig teuer es geht nicht hier um sowas wie Ubisoft Support
die denken leck mich am Arsch du hast das Spiel gekauft. Ne ne hier geht es wirklich
um Support der hunderttausende Euro kostet. Wo du Reaktionszeit bezahlst und ja so zumindest
das funktioniert so du machst bei Microsoft einen Support Call auf das heißt Call obwohl
es eigentlich ein schriftliches Ticket ist warum auch immer das Call heißt du machst
einen Support Call auf und das was passiert ist es reagiert innerhalb von 4 Stunden irgendeiner
drauf und was die machen ist die posten das was du geschrieben hast leicht anders formuliert
in das Ticket als Antwort und schreiben dann unten drunter noch wenn das ihr Problem gelöst
hat bitte schließen sie ihr Ticket. Jede Microsoft Support Anfrage läuft so die formulieren
deine Support Anfrage etwas um und fragen dich dann ob sich damit erledigt hat und damit
können sie sagen ja Reaktionszeit eingehalten. Ok Leute Any% Stream beenden es ist schon
spät Boomer müde Boomer muss ins Bett wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream machts gut bis
dann.